this morning i woke up decided to do my
morning pee
pulled my pants down and this guitar
pick fell out of my underwear
i don't know where it came from and i
don't know how that happened but
here it is
up gq it's conan gray and these are my
10 essentials
[Music]
alrighty this is my guitar
i have like seven or eight at this point
i don't know why
i'm not good at guitar let's get that
clear i'm actually very bad at it
i know like ten chords and i've written
all of my songs with the ten chords
it's a gibson that
was given to me i started playing guitar
when i was nine years old
and started writing songs when i was 12
because i heard an adele song and i
thought to myself i can write an adele
song that's easy
so i started writing songs and i don't
really know what my life would be like
if i didn't have
guitars in it this right here is my baby
this right here is my hydro flask i've
had this for
a very very long time if you can't tell
by how disgusting it is i kind of go by
the motive generally with things in my
life that
if you can reuse it reuse it the planet
is dying
as we speak so who gives a
crap if something is kind of ugly this
has been
all around the world with me as you can
tell by how
banged up it is but it's really it's
gone it's been on every stage i've ever
played there's a lot of like stickers
from
my life that's conan the detective who i
was named after
i was also named after conan the
barbarian just the most barbaric
human you've ever seen right i drink
like
maybe 10 or 11 of these a day
try to stay hydrated the only thing
that's annoying about staying hydrated
is you just like
have to pee all the time it's it seems
it's not very rewarding it almost makes
it not worth it i'd rather just be
dehydrated
life was fine when i was dehydrated but
i like this water bottle so i just drink
from it if i ever lose it
i think i will lose myself
this right here is my backpack it's a st
laurent backpack
kind of just matches anything it's just
a black backpack and it's very
kind of classic and beautiful it has
[Music]
several pockets i don't really carry
that much
with me other than just lots of trash so
i've had it for a couple years now i
really
can't imagine my life without this
backpack it's
it's kind of a buddy of mine at this
point it's very very
sturdy and hearty it's been through a
lot
i don't know how it looks normal after
what i've put it through
again i just kind of keep things around
when i like them
[Music]
these are my sunglasses these are
the pair that i've been liking lately
but i have a lot of pair of sunglasses i
kind of need them everywhere i go or
else i just start crying
i can't really see anything
unless i have sunglasses on normal light
is a lot for me i don't know who made me
like this but
i look outside in normal daylight and i
just start crying
i'm not sad most of the time i like
these
because kind of make me feel like an
alien sunglasses are one of those things
that you kind of just have to have fun
with
there's no point in being serious when
you can't even see outside
without glass in front of your eyeballs
so might as well just make them kind of
fun
this is my sunscreen this kind of feels
like a mom
pick i wear sunscreen every single day i
put it on
several times a day because that's what
is recommended i burn very very easily
i'm even partially sunburned right now
by doing nothing by just standing
outside for like 30 seconds
it's the irish in me can't help it
thanks
father this is a brand that i like i
also have multiples of them because i'm
just kind of dumb to be honest i will
pack
one and then i will
just forget that i've packed it and i'll
pack another and then i'll lose one and
then buy another
and then pack the other one so i have
two just in case anyone watching needs
one
i have a lot of them i'm realizing it's
probably a really lame thing to bring
on here but i don't care skin cancer is
not fun and if you
are prone to sun damage like i am
do this it'll be it's good for you do it
for me
some gucci clone perfume
if you ever wondered what i smell like i
smell like gucci guilty
with a combination of human skin
smell i got this i think in like
amsterdam a long time ago
it's very banged up like i said with all
of my things if i like something i just
keep it around
it smells like a nice store
or it smells like a like a you get in
like a car that's nice
or like an older car i don't know it
just smells good it's like a kind of
androgynous
scent it's also kind of like musky
and when combined with the smell of my
sweat
i think it smells alright it smells like
me
this is my jewelry i have a bunch of
kind of different things kind of all of
my jewelry kind of
mostly has sentimental value to me so
they're not like expensive things
they're all just kind of
things that mean something to me
actually almost all of my jewelry
is stuff that my friends have given me i
really really care about my friends
and so i kind of like to carry a piece
of them around
everywhere i go so like this is a little
shell necklace that my friend leo gave
me a ring that
a fan gave me this is a ring from howl's
moving castle
a witch if you've seen it you know
what's up i weirdly haven't gifted a lot
of jewelry to my friends even though
they always give me
their stuff i do like i feel like i give
my
friends clothes a lot i give them
clothes they give me jewelry it's a
equal tray
this is my journal i would
show you what's inside but then i would
have to murder you
so i won't to spare you there is a lot
of
content in here throughout the years i
have a very very very short attention
span so i have like
four or five different notebooks and
i'll kind of just write them whichever
one's
closest to me i've had this one since
2019
i know because i opened it up and
checked where the first entry was
and it was horrifying it was disgusting
it was really really gross so
i won't show you what's inside but this
is what it looks like
i write songs in here i write like poems
in here i write like random lines that i
think
of i generally write music kind of
on either a piece of paper or like in my
notes app on my phone or something like
that
when song ideas come i forget them
really fast because
like i said earlier i'm stupid so i have
to kind of record it
as quickly as i can somewhere so a lot
of it's kind of in videos and things
like that but it kind of just depends
there's like also a lot of
doodles in here i love to draw it's
pretty gross in here
this is a cliff bar i very often forget
to eat it's one of those things that i
just find tedious why do we have to eat
all the time it's like you eat then you
just have to keep eating
it's ridiculous i'll just like go
through the day and be like god
i feel terrible i feel like i'm dying i
wonder why
oh because all i've had all day is like
two almonds
and a cup of coffee so that's why you
feel like you're dying conan yeah
always have something like this around
this is a clif bar
chocolate chip flavored not my favorite
flavor i would say it's
number three number one is chocolate
chip peanut butter
that's the good good but this is this is
a great flavor
obvious choice of 2021
deeply essential at the moment hopefully
one day they won't be
but um at the moment they are the mask i
have several
i have this one which is can 95
very important this is a mask that
my mom and my sister made for me my
sister is a nurse so
she made this for me and i also have
hand sanitizer
i'm the friend that has some for
everyone just in case
they're very important lately i've been
like watching tv shows
and people will like not be wearing
masks and i'm like where are their masks
but they were filmed in like 2017 so
yeah that was prior to the world ending
thank you guys so much for watching that
was all of my essentials
i'm conor gray take care